[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre mission en face à
la première comme chat près une semaine
diffusé en direct le vendredi à 14h sur
notre site internet la première point fr
et puis en radio le dimanche à 12 heures
bonjour maurizio le temps avec lequel je
présente émission aujourd'hui bonjour
jean marc bourgeois toutes et à tous
pour recevoir deux dirigeants de la
république en marche ou la reine où elle
rer nous verrons ça avec eux tout à
l'heure tant que dirigeant de ce
mouvement d'une parti présidentiel en
martinique que tout d'abord à ma droite
charles de crissier bonjour vous êtes la
référente pour la martinique de la
république en marche et en face de vous
à notre gauche donc jacky le corps
entier bonjour bonjour subvertit qui est
le coordinateur de la république manche
vous à nous expliquer tout à l'heure les
particularités les subtilités et de ces
appellations puisque vous êtes les seuls
à les avoir dans l'univers politique
français et de martinique par conséquent
et comme d'habitude avant d'entrer dans
ce que le républicain marche représente
en martinique une question d'actualité
vont au hasard le dossier du chlordécone
cette semaine nous avons eu plusieurs
réunions de haut niveau entre le
gouvernement et les élus parlementaires
droit des antilles guadeloupe et
martinique
tout d'abord une réunion entre la
ministre de la santé la ministre le
ministre de la culture et la ministre d
outre-mer qui en voici le parlement
tueur de wall painting puis dans la même
journée mercredi dans la foulée la
ministre de la santé qui était
auditionné par la délégation de l'autre
maire de l'assemblée nationale qui ont
entre autres des députés d'outre-mer
tous ceux qui sont intéressés ou
involontairement pont s'intéresser aux
questions d'outre-mer sur la question du
chlordécone le gouvernement n'at-il pas
trop tardé à réagir à l'inquiétude de la
population et aux interpellations de nos
élus charles agression oui le
gouvernement alors il faudrait savoir
lequel
aujourd'hui oui mais le chlordécone
c'est pas un problème d'aujourd'hui on
voit les conséquences aujourd'hui
quand on se rappelle qu'il a été
introduit au début des années 70
particulièrement voilà c'est à dire
depuis pompidou bon ça va perdurer ou
aussi sous les régissent car destin il
était interdit dans les années donc en
90 mais avec une dérogation pour la
guadeloupe et la martinique donc ça
c'était sous françois mitterrand et puis
tolérer jusqu'en 2002 donc sous chirac
donc là on se situe en 2018 maintenant
donc effectivement se retrouvent
héritiers aussi d'une situation qui
comme beaucoup d'autres c'est pas que le
chlordécone la chlordécone
est devenue prioritaire pour les
martiniquais jacquelin gauthier
effectivement il faut être juste ne peut
pas reprocher au gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui en place depuis neuf mois
quelques erreurs en matière de
traitement de ce dossier mais on peut
lui reprocher sinon son silence en tout
cas ça ça gêne son nom bas rhin quant
aux nombreuses interpellations qui a eu
ces derniers mois oui je crois que c'est
comme je viens de le dire charlotte il
ya quelque chose qui est très important
c'est de rappeler que quand on prend une
des responsabilités ça tous niveaux
nous devons assumer la situation dans
lequel on la trouve
et cette situation elle est
effectivement catastrophique
est ce que vous êtes en train de
souligner c'est parce qu'il y avait un
élément supplémentaire
c'est par rapport à la décision de
l'europe qui est une décision
inacceptable et je le dis très
clairement c'est une décision de groupe
précisé la décision d'europe de
relèvement des heureusement voilà le
relèvement des tours d'eau autorisés
autorisé dans cette inaction
c'est inacceptable et tout ce qui est en
train tout ce qui s'est fait depuis
maintenant quelques semaines c'est dû à
ça en fait parce que le chlordécone on
n'en parlait plus et on en parle parce
que effectivement l'europe vient
d'accepter quelque chose qui est mais un
invraisemblable
donc là dessus nous nous battrons parce
que nous sommes avant tout en martinique
et nous nous battrons pour que cette
décision de l'europe ne soit pas ne soit
pas appliquée et ne soit pas prolongée
parce que c'est pas possible pas l'ami
de la santé l'a annoncé le
la décision européenne de ce relèvement
de ses taux va être finalement non
appliquées ne sera appliquée et le
député le team et a demandé que ce soit
écrit que l'arrêté du ministre
l'agriculture validant cette relèvement
soit purement et simplement annulée
et je pense que nous avons là encore une
prise de position du gouvernement
au même titre que sur d'autres dossiers
par rapport à l'europe où nous sommes
capables de faire la différence et je
suis moi très satisfait de voir que le
gouvernement et que la ministre a pris
cet engagement maintenant que monsieur
letchimy demande qu'ils soient écrits
forcément c'est mieux qu'ils soient
écrits vaut mieux vaut mieux mais mais
moi je crois quand même à la parole des
ministres parce que quand même nous
avons des ministres sérieux et quand ils
disent quelque chose avec un président
comme ils ont je pense qu'ils ont
intérêt à respecter ce qu'ils disent
excusez moi excusez moi je voudrais
aussi rappeler aussi la position du
président de la république emmanuel
macron plus généralement sur les
pesticides enfin contre les pesticides
on se rappelle de sa position pour le
glyphosate
donc même si la décision finale a été
prise selon le principe de collégialité
au niveau de l'union européenne la
france a été ferme emmanuel macron était
ferme c'était non de toute façon donc eu
l'idée aussi d'avoir cette position
concernant le chlordécone est de
reconnaître que certaines choses aussi
ne correspondent pas à la réalité
alors oui cela se dit tout cela se dit à
paris on en discute là bas mais est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que le
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui entend bien
cette exaspération
cette impression d'être des
laissés-pour-compte de la part des
martiniquais oui je pense que il a fallu
comme beaucoup de dossiers prendre le
temps aussi du diagnostic parce que on
connaît les problèmes depuis longtemps
mais c'est vrai que là et redemande
encore
on demande encore de nouveaux rapports
de nouvelles études qu'il faudrait
financer
et c'est justement cet aspect des choses
qui semblent excédés particulièrement la
population martiniquaise c'est pour ça
que je pense que la ministre
la santé agnès buzyn a pris le temps de
rencontrer les élus parce que ça c'est
sans précédent aussi de pouvoir les
recevoir et de pouvoir parler de tout en
toute transparence
je pense que c'était aussi ça l'idée
c'était de regrouper les parties
prenantes et aussi donc c'est les
aspects politiques et économiques mais
aussi de il y aura une enquête il ya une
enquête fin on sait très bien que il
faut pouvoir aussi mettre les gens en
face à leurs responsabilités c'est pour
ça que je vous parlais aussi de
l'historique du chlordécone et qu'il
faut revenir aussi aux sources pour
savoir qui a décidé à l'époque et dans
quel contexte
et comme si ce n'était pas suffisant on
parle également de pesticides au niveau
de la can
et forcément ça alimente tous ces
épisodes de passer oui mais je crois que
là vous soulevez un vrai problème c'est
à dire que mon émotion de reproduire les
mêmes erreurs mais c'est pas qu'on
reproduit les mêmes erreurs c'est que on
est dans un système économique qui fait
qu' il y a aujourd'hui des choses qui
sont totalement anormal qu'on sait qu'on
connaît mais qu'on laisse faire parce
que parce qu'il ya des lobbys et c'est
le bi faut arrêter ces lobbys donc je
pense qu'il ya des décisions à prendre
courageuse
je pense que le gouvernement prendrait
des décisions courageuses
le préfet doit réunir d'ailleurs
concernant le chlordécone doit réunir
l'ensemble des élus un des papas que les
parlementaires mais aussi les maires je
pense que vous vous avez entendu ce
matin un donc le préfet doit organiser
ça ça veut dire qu' il ne faut pas
rester à des limites mais il faut
descendre y compris dans la population
d'expliquer exactement ce que c'est sur
la traçabilité
il ya des choses aussi à faire en
martinique excuse-moi jacky justement
pour de manière concrète vous allez
monsieur beaudet qui est de passage
aussi en martinique qui lui avait
demandé
qui avait sensibilisé sur des
dispositifs concrets
parce qu'on sait que le club et la
chlordécone c'est pour on est parti pour
se conclure d'ici à une dizaine d'années
et certains le disent eux-mêmes la plus
de 50 ans bien plus de 50 ans et des
dispositif a été mis en place pour
pouvoir sensibiliser les populations
mais de manière concrète avec notamment
les jardins familiaux le retour au
jardin créole
des cultures alternatives aussi il
existe des interventions notamment par
la canne à sucre
on parle même du chanvre qui pourrait dé
polluer la terre en surface en tout cas
sur 50 cm de profondeur
est ce qu'on dit prêt à faire ça parce
que ça existe mais ça coûte cher tout
simplement bien ce gouvernement là
pourrait mettre l'argent sur la table
alors je crois encore que c'est comme
toutes les thématiques sait on parle on
parle bien souvent d'argent c'est
l'argent qu'on demande évidemment il est
nécessaire
mais il n'ya pas que l'argent il ya
aussi une vision à long terme parce que
si c'est encore une fois pour demander
de l'argent qui en fait va nourrir un
dispositif sans une stratégie c'est à
dire oui en voyant à long terme on voit
là ça sera encore ça sera encore inutile
là ce monsieur baudet s'il est venu
c'est parce que il a participé à la
sensibilisation avec des solutions
concrètes c'est pas des effets de mode
et on espère pouvoir aussi le rencontrer
parce que ce sont des personnes comme ça
qu'ils peuvent apporter des solutions et
mes pensées à long terme et dans
l'intérêt des martiniquais en tout cas
on aura noté le scepticisme d'un grand
nombre de députés dont celui de
martinique que je fais le pineau qui
sait de qui estime qu' à dire la
ministre de la santé que le gouvernement
finalement n'a pas véritablement pris la
mesure de cette crise sanitaire au sens
large du terme
est-ce que ce même député l'avait dit à
l'ancien gouvernement
mais écoutez il ya trois ans il avait
fait une intervention était passée sous
silence en un an le ministre de la santé
de l'époque n'ont pas voulu répondre si
vous avez la question comment avoir été
là ça va aller plus vite puisque déjà la
ministre a déjà pris une décision donc
vous voyez que ya déjà un progrès mais
peut être votre rôle vos coordinateur
vous référant de la république en marche
ici en martinique est ce que vous
utilisez le le circuit
vos représentants de l' dans marche ici
vous appeler les responsables nationaux
dommage qu'on dira là il ya peut-être
quelque chose à faire il faut être très
prudent il faut mettre un coup
d'accélérateur sur le site existe ce
circuit
écoutez monsieur viol ton c sur
l'ensemble des dossiers que nous faisons
ce travail c'est à dire que c'est vrai
qu'on a entendu un petit peu ici ou là
de dire la république en marche ou en
marche mais j'aime bien en marche
martinique eux on les entend pas mais
c'est pas parce qu'on à bois que on est
efficace nous on travaille on fait
remonter des choses et on a fait
remonter des choses sur le chu on a fait
remonter des choses sur un certain
nombre de dossiers dont on parlera
peut-être est ce à ce que vous êtes en
train de dire
évidemment le fait sur tous les dossiers
nous avons des interlocuteurs en marche
paris qui eux mêmes ont des
interlocuteurs au niveau des ministères
est pour rien vous cacher nous avons
aussi des interlocuteurs directs au
niveau du ministère parce que je vous
rappelle que c'est difficile de le
quantifier l'aimé autant d'émotions
vieux temps permettez moi de finir pour
la première fois ce gouvernement a mis
un un responsable dans chaque ministère
pour l'outre-mer c'est la première fois
que ça existe j'ai fait de bons un
référent un référent dans chaque
ministère pour l'outre-mer donc ça veut
dire que le président de la république
considère les outre-mer comme quelque
chose d'excessivement important
donc je crois qu'on ne peut pas en six
mois régler ce qui ne s'est pas fait en
50 ans où en 33 40 ans ou 20 ans je
crois que l'histoire montre que les
outre mer ont été oubliés je crois que
le président de la république a dans sa
politique dans sa campagne électorale
amy l'outre-mer devant je pense que les
ministres qui sont déjà venus en
martinique montre que l'outre-mer est un
intérêt pour la france et également pour
l'europe
je pense que c'est important alors de
votre présentation
évidemment je veux consternant sur la
question d'actualité puisque vous êtes
résident en martinique notre bon pour
une fois qu'on a quelqu'un de maquereaux
nist officielle parce que vous savez que
pendant la période électorale s'est
passé certes on y reviendra mais on a eu
parfois un peu de mal à savoir qui est
qui qui vont présenter exactement ses
fils manière le maquereau louis
commssion comme je le disais
effectivement c'est fini alors vos
charlotte gressier vous êtes comme andy
gray j'ai une jeune femme qui a décidé
de mettre référente puisque ça s'est
fait sous le sous sol un processus de
candidature et vous et finalement vous
avez été validé à la surprise générale
en intérêts à l'extérieur parce que vous
avez été accusé tout de suite de ne pas
être connu et donc il ya peut-être des
quelques quelques précisions apportées
si on ça et donc c'est un peu difficile
servant qui vous êtes en effet puisque
vous n'avez pas encore d'expérience
politique ou électorale et donc je suis
j'étais obligée d'aller voir un peu ce
qu'on dit de vous un peu partout vous
êtes très discrète sur les réseaux
sociaux
est-ce que c'est volontaire ou quand je
n'en sais en tout cas sur le site
internet de la république manche en
apprend que vous n'êtes ni relance
inique évidemment de mère indienne de
guadeloupe et d'un père qui originaire
des hauts de france dans le nom de la
france et qui partage sa vie entre
martinique par vider le monde vous avez
été consultante vous avez d'aiguillon
cabinet de l'eau vous avez travaillé
dans un cabinet de lobbying à bruxelles
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous faites
dans la civile si je veux dire à part
votre engagement politique
alors la première chose c'est que
concrètement j'en ai un peu assez en
fait qu'on me pose la question je crois
que je me suis justifié
plus que de raison ce que je sais c'est
qu'à 34 ans le 16 mars
voilà je sais que l'âge et la sagesse ne
vont pas forcément main dans la main ça
se saurait se serait vu concrètement
notamment en martinique
ça c'est la première chose à qui vous
pensez en particulier de sa ville
on n'est pas dans l'ancien journalisme
où on était dans une délation qui en
fait n'apporte rien aux martiniquais je
pense pas qu'on est là pour donner des
noms et que les gens avec un peu de bon
sens savent très bien de qui on parle
je ne sais plus votre question c'est est
oui parce que je sais ce qu'est ce que
vous faites de votre de vos journées de
votre vie de ma journée de demain
journée qui fait peu de 24 heures je
suis en charge de la création d'un musée
sur l'histoire de la martinique
voilà projet fou aux signes secteur
public le projet privé et on espère
pouvoir aussi intéressés
oui le public puisque c'est dans
l'intérêt de la martinique c'est
l'histoire de la martinique donc ça me
paraît logique que ce soit un projet en
collaboration avec toutes les forces
vives et vous jacky le corps entier vous
avez été adjoint au maire puis maire de
la ville de plaisir dans les yvelines en
région parisienne les années 1990 vous
êtes originaire si je puis dire du parti
socialiste pourquoi être parti de du ps
finalement partie du ps parce que si
vous voulez je pense que moi je suis un
socialiste de de ce que j'appellerais de
l'ancienne génération cette génération
mitterrand
cette génération michel rocard j'étais
très proche de michel rocard puisque
c'était dans mon département et j'ai été
pendant dix ans sans bras droit donc
quand j'ai vu emmanuel macron si vous
voulez quantité ministre
son comportement son attitude ses
paroles j'ai retrouvé un michel rocard
moi qui avais la chance de suivre au
quotidien
j'ai retrouvé un michel roca je me suis
dit c'est un homme d'avenir et le parti
socialiste était déjà dans une dans une
phase
je dirais deux pas des compositions
parce que c'est pas très sympa dire ça
mais n'était plus le vrai parti
socialiste alors est ce que ce sont les
sottises les vrais socialistes qui ne
sont plus socialiste ou est ce que c'est
le parti socialiste qui a complètement
changé d'orientation
je crois que la réponse enfin ma réponse
à moi c'est que c'est le parti
socialiste qui a changé complètement
d'orientation genre de deux maux de l
héroïne
comment vous préférez vous vous faire
appeler lrm la république en marche
parce que ya toutes les appellations
latines en marche martinique
c'est vrai qu'au départ c'est la
république en marche mal
c'est simplement des raisons de
sonorités parce que ça arrivait aussi
assez facilement les gens on écoute
aussi les gens puisqu'on part de la base
et on nous dit on nous appelle en marche
en marche martinique
comment va en marche pas alors oui
justement bonnes questions comme enfin
martinique qui est un martini quels sont
vos militants voit ses partisans comment
vous êtes comment vous organisez-vous
qui sait que finalement pas si ce que
les visions alors on vous ne parlez pas
beaucoup on ne vous entend pas beaucoup
mais c'est l'occasion
est-ce que des troupes grossistes
notamment depuis que vous êtes vous avez
été désigné et référente facile oui
alors déjà donc comme on l'a déjà dit
auparavant il ya une vraiment une phase
de nettoyage
ça c'est fait c'est dit nettoyage de
nettoyage oui mais ça je me suis déjà
expliqué il faut aller dessus donc je
pense qu'on peut passer concrètement oui
on a une équipe qui s'agrandit
concernant les comités comme s'expliquer
qu'on est organisé par comité par ville
en trois mois et demi on est passé de
deux comités adou ce comité
donc c'est une très bonne chose avec un
animateur
dédié à chaque comité local d'accord
comité on regroupe les militants dans
une commune d'azay nouvelle tout à fait
d'accord donc pour ce marché digérant
millière il complique pas pour l'instant
on a un petit peu nord sud de centre
vous avez abandonné le schéma de la
circonscription oui oui oui parce que
c'est plus d'actualité et nous avions
fait et là je vous permet de prendre la
parole parce que c'était l'époque où
j'étais déjà coordinateur de charlotte
n'était pas n'était pas là nous avions
fait par circonscription pourquoi parce
que nous étions en pleine présidentielle
et ensuite nous allions avoir les
législatifs donc il était normal de
s'adapter à la circonstance du moment la
circonstance du moment étant passé donc
nous avons supprimé ces comités de
circonscription et nous avons fait des
comités de ville
donc c'est beaucoup plus dur de faire
des comités de ville parce que des
comités deal c'est ville par ville donc
ça veut dire que là aussi nous prenons
beaucoup de précautions pour éviter il
doit chercher ces personnes quand vous
disiez macro macro compatible c'est
maintenant complètement compatible là
c'est pas des personnes seront
compatibles quelqu'un qui décide de 2,2
de prendre la responsabilité d'un comité
il est à en marche ce qui peut aussi et
cherche un nouveau souffle après avoir
été échaudé par exemple dans une
démarche personnelle municipal par
exemple je jeu on n'a pas ce cas là au
pied non vraiment je vais déjà non non
il ya il ya eu il a pu y avoir des cas
comme ça mais c'est vrai on a eu aussi
cette fermeté de fermer des comités de
gens qui avaient des intentions qui
était peut-être celle que vous êtes en
train de de faire allusion ce fait le
ménage
je pense que c'est important de le dire
que notre objectif
il est d'avoir des gens sincères d'avoir
des gens qui ont comme seul objectif
l'intérêt majeur de la martinique et non
pas l'intérêt personnel alors pour
militants
teintes sont ils ont-ils été auparavant
des militants politiques ce sont des
personnes qui ont une expérience
électorale ou dans une formation
politique ou pas est ce que il ya une
typologie qu'elle sait le jeu les
ralentis typologie c'est à dire qu'en
fait on reçoit tous les âges toutes les
couleurs tous les horizons toutes les
formations encore voilà on est en étant
vigilant aussi sur comment ça se passe
maurizio lé temps par exemple de la
commune cet esprit au hasard veut
devenir adhérent de marche maintenant il
fait non je plaisante
eh bien écoutez vous pouvez nous
contacter et on vous rencontre on
échange avec vous
et on parle très librement de votre
passant de 500 revu mon parcours non non
c'est pas un recrutement un entretien
c'est une conversation libre
où on apprend à se connaître voilà c'est
vrai que les liens humains c'est devenu
un petit peu presque subversif mais chez
nous c'est le fondement
donc la base c'est l'humanité donc on se
parle simplement et puis on essaie de
voir ensemble si en fait vos convictions
vont avec l'intérêt général de la
martinique si vous avez envie de faire
des choses concrètes
après ça dépend aussi de ce que vous
voulez faire vous pouvez être si vous
avez l'âme de leader vous pouvez être un
animateur de comité local si vous
préférez aussi plutôt travailler être
voilà sous l'égide de quelqu'un
travailler en groupe
voilà si vous avez un domaine de
prédilection vous pouvez être personnes
ressources
c'est dire si votre votre truc c'est
l'agriculture vous avez des compétences
et que vous êtes fiable vous pouvez pas
ce que ça c'est bon à rappeler aussi on
fonctionne en équipe c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui on est là tous les deux
jacky et moi mais l'idée aussi c'est de
permettre à des gens qui ont une
fiabilité et une compétence du pouvoir
s'exprimer c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
pour la chlordécone on aurait pu aussi
avoir quelqu'un qui serait venu
spécialement et qui voilà qui serait
même plus pointu que nous parce qu'on a
aucun problème avec ça on appelle avec
pour objectif quand même de préparer
déjà le terreau est de poser des jalons
objectifs 2020 et 2021
mais monsieur jiva municipal je le
soutiens d'abonnement je me souviens
d'avoir fait une émission avec vous et
vous m'avez fait cette réflexion me dire
mais vous n'avez aucun élu en marche
donc vous n'êtes pas audible
ce qui est je vous ai dit vous avez
raison nous n'avons à ce jour à ce jour
officiellement aucun élu donc il est
évident qu'un parti politique
il est là pour aller aux élections sinon
si c'est pour faire du folklore envoie
au carnaval
donc nous sommes un parti politique donc
nous irons aux élections je vous l'avais
dit lors de notre entretien
donc je vous le confirme et d'autant
plus que si nous faisons des comités par
ville vous imaginez bien que quand je
vous ai expliqué qu on a fermé les
comités au niveau des circonscriptions
et qu'on les met au niveau des villes
six pour aller aux municipales et qui
découle des municipales découle
forcément la ctm là je voulais juste
vous rappeler comme son bilan face à la
première sur martinique la première
c'est pour nos internautes éviter ans
avec deux dirigeants de la république à
marshall officier qui voilà qui va avoir
la parole tout de suite et jacky le
compte y est allé du malawi je voulais
simplement résumé parce que je dirais
qu'il ya beaucoup de digressions il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire aussi donc en
fait si vous voulez
ja le comité de pilotage dans lequel on
a des personnes ressources qui ont un
domaine précis de compétences et pas en
dessous parce que on n'est pas dans
cette logique là mais on a des comités
par ville avec un animateur et donc
l'idée c'est que ces comités par ville
avec l'animateur puisse s'organiser
autour d'une personne ressource
lorsqu'il va lui travailler un thème
particulier pour faciliter à dispersion
est ce que vous avez un timing ans ferme
comment donc pour parler en mauvais
français en france à cannes en oublier
les financiers pour dévoiler présenter
ses animateurs et animatrices c'est
différent parce qu'on ne sait pas qui
ils sont finalement oui alors si vous
voulez on a d'abord tout un travail que
nous faisons ensemble ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des gens de la
société civile vous êtes des gens qui
ont fait de la politique d'autres qui
n'en n'ont pas fait donc on est on est
on est entre nous déjà des réunions
régulières
actuellement c'est une fois tous les
quinze jours ont réuni tous nos comités
donc voyez qu'on travaille beaucoup on
nous entend pas mais on travaille
beaucoup et pour mettre je dirais qu'on
n'en ont jamais parlé
monsieur a voulu mais eux mais pas du
tout mais monsieur qu'est le temps ça
sert à quoi que je vous dise que
monsieur bidule ou madame truquée les
responsables du comité de ça pour
l'instant ça sert à rien nous allons
avoir dans l'est dans les dents les dans
les jours qui viennent d'ici peu de
temps une conférence de presse que nous
allons que nous allons faire pour vous
faire des annonces qui voit des annonces
excessivement importante donc peut donc
c'est quelque chose dont permettez nous
on a fait à ce jour nous avons fait une
seule conférence de presse qui était
quoi c'est moi qui les dirigent et pour
vous annoncer la la résistance de chaque
dossier l'existence non je pense qu'il
existe pas besoin de l'annoncé
l'existence mais la nation la
désignation de charlotte gressier et de
l'équipe et et de l'équipe de duck et
est présente là nous allons si nous
faisons une conférence de presse vous
imagine bien ce n'est pas pour vous
faire venir pour vous dire la même chose
que ce qu'on est en train de vous dire
donc qu'il y aura une annonce la
conférence de presse sera le 7 mars
donc vous serez vous êtes bien sûr déjà
invités dont il y aura des annonces pour
vous dire comment nous évoluions raté
d'une manière la veille de la journée
internationale de lutte des droits des
femmes alors
qu'est ce que vous allez faire aux
élections municipales il ya
trente-quatre communes donc blanche sera
présent dans les 34 communes logiquement
si vous voulez notre notre politique de
pardon municipal est très clair je viens
de la vente publique
à ce jour nous rencontrons nous avons
demandé une audience à l'ensemble des
maires de la martinique
parce que c'est une correction donc nous
avons demandé et nous avons déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de mères qui nous ont
reçus et des lions nous sommes tout à
l'heure reçu par le maire de fort de
france
donc il nous en reste encore à voir ça
prend du temps
imaginez bien que c'est pas un rendez
vous de 10 minutes 1 c'est sont des
rendez vous très long puisque bien sûr
on les gens s'interrogent les maires
s'interroge quel va être votre position
notre position est très claire
notre position est de dire nous ne
sommes pas là pour dire avec nos gros
bras on va arriver présenter des
candidats partout et puis de dire on va
apprendre des municipalités non c'est
pas c'est pas notre logis notre logique
elle et de dire il ya des mères
aujourd'hui qui font excessivement bien
leur travail dans l'intérêt de leurs
concitoyens dans l'intérêt de la
martinique et ces merdes là on leur dit
nous nous avons envie de venir partager
cette expérience avec vous vous avez dit
je suis un ancien maire donc je connais
bien ce que c'est qu'un maire et un
maire avant tout c'est se préoccuper de
ses concitoyens au quotidien et croyez
moi que vous soyez de droite de gauche
de la république en marge ou quoi que ce
soit ça peu d'importance qui est
important c'est qu'est ce que vous
faites pour vos concitoyens
ça c'est la vie municipale c'est ça et
ça c'est notre logique de dire au maire
voilà nous on vous propose de venir
renforcer votre équipe
mais à une seule condition c'est que
nous gardions notre identité ça veut
dire que nous formions au sein de votre
majorité cissé on cite cet imagier nous
formons un groupe en marche ça s'est
maintenu les maires qui sont macro
compatible sujet pour les mêmes laden
videmment mais il pour les autres
pour les autres nous aurons des listes
et nous serons dans l'opposition si nous
perdons est ce que vous avez fait une
évaluation du nombre de communes dans
lesquelles
pourquoi y être présent souvent propres
couleurs ou des deux dans les autres
communes où vous soyez présent on sait
sinon des majorités sur la file pour
essayer de répondre clairement à votre
question qui est une question très
difficile dans la mesure où on n'a pas
vu tout le monde tous ceux qui nous ont
répondu à ce jour sont ont la vision de
dire on est d'accord avec votre position
mais il ya des gens qui nous ont pas
reçu donc ça veut dire que lausanne et
le fait que le mauvais reste à venir
vous allez voir principalement les
maires d'une martinique quand même
essentiellement des mères nous voyons
les verts à gauche autonome et
maintenant nous voyons tout le monde
nous voyons tout le monde ouais on voit
aujourd'hui à maire ppm
oui nous avons vu le maire de du
saint-esprit qui et les républicains
nous avons vu d'autres maires qui sont
d'autres couleurs politiques
nous n'avons pas nous nous engageons en
mettant en avant que vous êtes parti
centriste que ça peut aider aussi
mais on n'est pas un parti centriste on
a un parti qui accepte tout le monde
sait pas du tout la même chose pourquoi
vous voulez nous mettre une étiquette
centriste
monsieur viol tombe vous n'avez pas
compris qu est ce qu était la république
en marge la république en marche c'est
que le président de la république l'a
dit
toutes les bonnes volontés sont là pour
faire une transformation du pays
pas pour faire des réformes ou des
réformes slv conception de la politique
maîtresse en effet mais ce vieux
principe de journalistes mais alors vous
avez une réponse d'un politique
alors il y à un autre vous connaissez
nos clivages politiques ici oui en
longtemps et gilles ont existé même
s'ils sont en train de disparaître de se
fondre dans un nouveau paysage
idéologique et politique
nous étions pendant très longtemps
traversé par un fort courant autonomiste
enfants courant indépendantiste et un
fort courant
un livret de cet article de
conservateurs on disait
départementaliste aujourd'hui en afrique
sens puisque nous sommes nous avons même
été du parent tellement pendant 70 ans
aujourd'hui ces clivages n'ont plus
tellement lieu d'être puisque même si
les étiquettes existe dans la réalité
politique quotidienne de la gestion des
collectivités positionnement de nos élus
politiques d'une formation politique
on ne voit pas trop comment que se
traduire ce discours une autonomie ce
discours d'indépendance au ce disque aux
conservateurs de statu quo qui ne n'est
plus tenable
évidemment alors comment vous
situez-vous dans ce paysage politique en
perpétuel mouvement et charlotte
précieux alors la première chose pour
faire un lien avec jacky nous n'avons
pas d'ennemi déjà c'est la première
chose donc on rencontre tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est que on a un
outil précieux qui est l'article 73 de
la constitution la constitution qui est
une boîte à outils merveilleuse dans le
sens où elle a tous les instruments
possibles pour réadapter certaines
choses sauf qu'elle n'est pas ouverte
cette boîte c'est à dire elle n'est pas
utilisée bonjour je passe est écrit au
jour d'aujourd'hui
par défaut pour l'instant on n'a pas eu
de retour
d'élus qui aurait ouvert la boîte pour
aller voir concrètement ce qu'il est
possible de faire et dans les
obligations notamment mais plus
globalement dans les possibilités de
réadaptation de la loi parce que l'idée
c'est de de défendre une autonomie qui
serait une autonomie plus plus plastique
en fait et on prenait le cas de la corse
qui en fait n'est pas comparable c'est
vrai que certains pourraient utiliser le
les desiderata aussi de certains pour
changer de statut mais c'est pas
comparable
avant c'est ce que disaient les mains
emmanuel macron aux corses
avant même d'aller briller un autre
article
et c'est utiliser ont déjà ce qu'on
n'utilise pas pour l'instant ce qui a
énormément de choses à faire
sauf qu'il ya encore ce qu'ils ont 25
ans d'expérience les élus les la
population 25 ans d'expérience de la
collectivité territoriale à une
supervision et ils sont arrivés ils
disent qu'ils sont arrivés un peu au
bout du bout du bout en bout du système
beaucoup de logique du système et donc
ils souhaiteraient progresser
quitte à avoir un chapitre que la
constitution spécifiquement consacré à
la cance tout comme la nouvelle
calédonie par exemple sur l'article 71
cents sur l'article 67 jours sur
l'article 71 nous sommes sur le 73
oui c'est vrai nous sommes bien avancés
sont heureux c'est le discours était
justement ces screens élégance demande
de déverrouiller la macro a déçu en
disant pas question bouge pas mais il
faut faire attention à une chose c'est
que avec la république en marche l'idée
c'est aussi de tenir compte de
différentes réalités locales pas pour
nationale mais aussi des réalités
locales autres territoires ultramarins
dire que la corse la nouvelle calédonie
et la martinique c'est le même
fonctionnement c'est la même réalité est
qu'on aurait tous crient à
l'indépendance ça n'est pas possible
et encore faut-il être prêt à voir des
compétences et aussi avoir une vision à
long terme
là on a un outil comme je vous dis qui
est incroyable et dans lequel on peut
avoir des réadaptations qui sont
vraiment cons qui corresponde à la
réalité locale vous faites est quoi ce
que le président du ppm c'est un jeu qui
me disait il ya quelques mois on veut ni
hao discours initial de l'autonomie mais
dans le cadre de l'article 73 parce que
dit-il en résumant de beaucoup sa pensée
l'article 73 permet d innovation de
l'expérimentation des possibilités qui
ne sont pas encore ouvertes ou offertes
aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes d'accord avec le
président du pp à monsieur ce plan là
mais je crois que si vous voulez oui je
crois que vous dites reparler de
l'autonomie mais ses passes il y en a
marre de parler faut travailler
maintenant il faut se mettre au travail
ça veut dire qu'il faut ouvrir cette
boîte de 73 regarder ce qu'il ya dedans
et parler et le député le député serge
letchimy quelqu'un excessivement
compétents je pense qu'il est capable de
faire des adaptations des lois votées
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale et
étant totalement adapté à la martinique
et il ya cette possibilité dans la
version serait le martiniquais de de
travailler pour avoir plus d'autonomie
mais je mets je demande
je demande aux martiniquais d'être
logique avec eux mêmes ils ont voulu
l'article 73 de la constitution ce qui
le met en application
je ne leur demande pas de travailler
mais je ne dis pas que je ne travaille
pas ça veut dire quoi mettre en
application cette boîte à outils est
fermée samedi on voit concrètement
comment mais ça veut dire que à
aujourd'hui
l'article 73 permet d expérimentation au
delà et le président de la république a
bien dit l'expérimentation veut dire
qu'on peut se tromper on peut ce saurien
tu es bien quelque chose s'ajuster voir
reculer si nous nous sommes trompés
je vous donne un exemple très clair à
aujourd'hui vous avez une ctm qui est un
qui a un gir un statut avec deux de deux
têtes
oui david hinde président du conseil
exécutif mais ça veut rassembler moi
j'estime cas aujourd'hui ça a été fait
sans que avec une une bonne volonté je
suppose
avec une bonne volonté le constat c'est
qu'on a le sentiment que ça fonctionne
pas donc il faut avoir le courage de
dire de dire ben il vaut mieux peut-être
faire marche arrière pour la prochaine
et refaire une assemblée où il n'y a
qu'une seule tête parce que les deux
têtes fonctionne pas donc vous avez
l'exemple de la guyane qui a une seule
tête on a l'impression que ça marche
mieux donc voilà l'expérimentation ça
veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on
tient ça mange bien comment encore s'il
ya peut-être mais ça marche
mu est en tête en corse il ya deux têtes
depuis peu de temps puisqu'il ce nom
mais ça ne la réunion la réunion des
deux collectivités n'est pas vieille
elle est tout récent il ya une assemblée
et d'un exécutif exactement l'arrêt
depuis très longtemps
oui c'est très bien dosé qui fonctionne
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres ce que
je veux dire celles que l'on sait que il
faut pouvoir freiner et c'est le
président de la république dit même une
entreprise l'entreprise a droit à
l'erreur donc les politiques aussi ont
droit à l'erreur quand le politique aura
compris que les politiques n'ont pas la
science infuse
donc quand le politique fera une
expérimentation et qu'il a le courage de
dire maintenant ça ne va pas on revient
et on fait autrement parce que eh ben
c'est du courage politique ça s'appelle
du courage politique
je pense que le président de la
république donne cette possibilité dont
vous l'apprendre sherlock précis selon
vous qu'est ce qui empêche cette
expérimentation chez nos élus
aujourd'hui il faudrait leur demander
pour aujourd'hui dans des querelles de
personnes peut-être les conflits d'ego
je crois qu'on en a déjà parlé aussi
plusieurs fois
voilà il faut il faut pouvoir passer à
autre chose parce qu'en fait plus
globalement on ne nous attend pas
enfin ma mère et droit de louper le dis
souvent regarde ce qui se passe en
guadeloupe c'est vrai que la guadeloupe
elle avance 1
et pour tout vous dire moi ça me fend le
coeur de savoir que quand on va à
bruxelles parce que moi je vais aller
jusqu'à bruxelles pour savoir
concrètement ce qui se passe parce que
la politique c'est pas qu'une politique
locale pour la martinique
le débat en ce moment l'idée qui sort
c'est de savoir si la martinique se
place avant ou après mayotte alors moi
personnellement j'ai rien contre
majorque ce qui l'est moins c'est à dire
parce que par rapport aux régions
ultrapériphériques une terme un peu
barbare mais disons que dans ce groupe
là au niveau européen
vous avez différentes il est
effectivement la martinique s'il fallait
la côte est ou faire une espèce de
classement et paraît très très loin et
mayotte c'est quand même là il me semble
la deuxième région la plus pauvre
d'europe
je suis désolée la martinique a
tellement de choses à proposer être
force de proposition être poste avancé
stratégique pour pour tous pour la
défense comme la fin voilà on va pas
revenir dans tous les atouts qui peuvent
apporter
je pense que là il faut il faut passer à
autre chose parce que le monde lui ne
nous attend pas et les fonds européens
non plus d'ailleurs qui vont repartir
vous avez l'intention en marche de
bousculer nos habitudes politiques c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est en lisant la
charte la charte des valeurs de marche
ainsi disponibles sur internet donc on
peut s'en sont inspirés n'est ce pas on
puisse s'instruire en tout cas et vous
avez l'intention de remettre les
français au coeur de la vie politique
ces mouvements dites-vous n'est pas une
addition d'individus mais le
rassemblement de personnes engagées qui
partagent un socle de valeurs et la
volonté de regarder la réalité en face
pour mieux la transformer fin de
citation bon oui mais je crois vous avez
tout résumé n'ai pas besoin
d'explications supplémentaires ça veut
dire que rassembler les gens pour faire
une transformation et je crois que le
discours du président de la république a
toujours été celui là maintenant c'est
remet pas en cause les choix qu'il faut
être très honnête on va pas remettre en
cause ce qui a été fait je pense qu'il
ya des choses qui sont très positives
d'autres moins on n'est pas là dans un
dans faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
je crois qu il faut s est pas la
révolution c'est la transformation c'est
pas la révolution c'est la
transformation c'est claire blanchard
l'onu mais si les jeunes femmes vous
avez dit votre foot alors je le rappelle
34 transformer la réalité transformer le
pays transformé la martinique ça veut
dire quoi pour vous personnellement
c'est refuser la réforme est refusée la
mesure est c'est à dire accepter que les
choses prennent du temps
aussi parce qu'en fait ce serait
malhonnête de notre part d'essayer de
vous convaincre de l'efficacité de
certaines mesures à court terme tout de
suite ça serait malhonnête et je crois
que
il faut arrêter d'être l'homme politique
sachant qui sait tout qui a réponse à
tout cas des chiffres à l'appui qu'ont
parfois on dit pas non plus chaque chose
en son temps
voilà les choses à sa lutte en relation
sans cesse impatiente celle qui souffre
depuis un certain temps et qui a massé
et face à des jeunes qui quittent le
pays parce qu'ils estiment que ça ne va
pas assez vite
oui surtout surtout face aux impatients
comme on disait tout à l'heure agir dans
la hat n'est pas forcément le gage d'une
efficacité sur le terrain la situation
est complexe et comme je vous ai dit
prendre une mesure localement ça aussi
un impact par rapport à l'intégration
régionale caribéenne par rapport au
national par rapport aux six européens à
bruxelles
donc là il faut vraiment garder ça en
tête donc une transformation c'est un
processus qui prend alors qui prend le
temps qu'il doit prendre mais on disait
que le principe de base c'est l
expérimentation et ça je pense que c'est
un gage d'honnêteté c'est pas parce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est parce que
justement on voudrait être efficace mais
à long terme donc expérimentation ces
stratégies proposées solution on essaye
et on accepte de se dire où ça marche
ou alors ça ne marche pas et dans ce cas
là en fait les réajustements nécessaires
les 24 et 35 ans les c'est qu'ils ont
terminé leurs études qui ont commencé à
travailler qui a envie d'aller chercher
un move party qu'il y ait finning
quelque part dans le monde parce que
ailleurs ça bouge ça pulse comme on dit
vous leur dites quoi et on allait vivre
vos expériences la mer rhône ici en
martinique et maintenant ce que vous
avez accumulé
moi je pense que les journalistes ont un
rôle aussi important ce serait alors
peut-être que ça a déjà été fait mais il
y a encore tant d'exemples de deux
jeunes puisque vous prenez les jeunes
mais il ya aussi des moins jeunes comme
c'est le cas qu'ils sont partis écoute
c'est le mercredi au parcours
d'exception
vous voyez ça fait partie des choses
mais il faut pouvoir le démultiplier sa
montre et qu'aussi il ya des gens qui
réussissent parce que le problème en
martinique
c'est le manque de fierté une fierté
scène c'est à dire de pouvoir se
projeter en se disant je ne suis pas une
victime
je suis un survivant je suis capable
d'apporter quelque chose au monde
je pense que c'est libéraux sur doit
faire référence à des personnages de
dessins animés que nous connaissons
mieux monsieur des ateliers non et je
crois que charlotte viennent dire
quelque chose de très vrai si les jeunes
pas déjà ils partent pour souvent finir
leurs études et le seul problème qui
l'on sait que quand ils ont un regard de
l'extérieur de la martinique ils ont
surtout envie de parvenir
donc c'est à nous ici en place et c'est
un métropolitain qui vous le dis donc
c'est à nous ici en martinique de leur
donner l'envié de revenir parce que
quand on voit le potentiel qu'il y ait
en martinique
tous ces jeunes pourraient revenir mais
il faudrait aussi qu'on qu'ils aient
confiance dans leurs classes politiques
qu'ils aient confiance dans un certain
nombre de domaines et qu'il ne voit que
les choses ont changé et la population
comme vous dites qui souffrent cette
population si aujourd'hui elle ne vote
pas elle ne veut plus c'est qu'il ya une
raison
ils sont blasés
ils se disent si de toute façon c'est
comme ça et pas autrement
donc non il faut pas se décourager et
notre rôle il est de leur dire non cet
ensemble avec tout le monde c'est pour
ça que charlotte disait nous n'avons pas
d'ennemi il n'est pas question de dire
on des meilleurs que les autres non vous
avez des sujets qui sont aujourd'hui sur
l'actualité il faut que les gens
arrivent à se mettre autour de la table
et arrive à trouver des consensus pour
dire nous devons arriver à faire avancer
la martinique alors les assises de
l'autre merde on s'ils ont pris c'est
une sorte de contre-pied du milieu du
président et du gouvernement qui
consiste à organiser la consultation
quelques années à une petite dizaine
d'années après les états généraux de
l'outre-mer dos aux dépenses scepticisme
qu'il y avait ici ou là chez les
décisions chez la population et encore
on va nous demander notre avis notre
opinion nos analyses nos projets on a
déjà fait puis ça n'a pas servi à grand
chose à quoi ça sert
alors est ce que c'est une tentative de
définition d'une nouvelle vision du
domaine de l'outre-mer des outre-mer ont
commandé poli pour être politiquement
correct ou alors c'est vu comme ça peut
être vu aussi comme une absence de
vision de l'autre au nez cette
convocation des comptes de chacun des
français vivent des socioprofessionnels
des politiques mais également de la
population pour participer à ces assises
de l'outre-mer qui sont en train de se
terminer la recherche décide alors de
manière très sincèrement on avait déjà
parlé aussi au début
moi j'avais connu les états généraux de
l'outre-mer en 2009 donc effectivement
quand j'ai vu apparaître aussi les
assises je me suis dit c'est que
certaines choses n'avaient donc pas
fonctionné poker ne vaut les assises de
l'outre-mer donc je pense que beaucoup
de gens ont pris cet événement avec
certains voilà des pincettes
en revanche et le préfet de la
martinique franck robine le disais on a
eu une grande surprise d'avoir une
grande participation des martiniquais
pour les assises
une participation qui était d'ailleurs
plus conséquente que les réunionnais eux
mêmes non c'est pas voilà c'est les
réunionnais bon c'est devenu un petit
peu aussi une référence en matière
oui enfin bon quand vous regardez le
chanteur will i l'utilisation des fonds
européens en termes de d'entrepreneuriat
et projet c'est les réunionnais qui
arrive en avant en avant donc mais c'est
bien c'est ça peut être un premier de
cordée aussi on n'a pas de problème avec
ça et
oui et donc les martiniquais ont
participé et donc franck robine trouvais
que c'était effectivement déjà un espoir
de renouveau et en particulier avait
souligné un effort fait de propositions
par les martiniquais en termes de
dialogue social aussi donc ça c'est
assez important
et puis je pense qu'il faut pouvoir
aussi intégrer les assises donc comme
une première étape
on va pas encore une fois voilà on va
pas transformer et changer le monde ça
serait mentir que de dire que voilà avec
les assises au 1er avril votre vie a
changé ça c'est faux c'est vraiment pour
faire remonter les dossiers et alors
faire le diagnostic en tout cas à
nourrir ce diagnostic de concret parce
que je pense que tout le monde en a un
peu marre aussi de des diagnostics
concrètement est de savoir aussi que les
assises ça fait partie d'un processus
plus large qui est celui de redonner
confiance puisque la confiance ça fait
partie aussi du projet d' emmanuel
macron et de simplifier aussi les
relations entre usagers entreprises
comme le droit à l'erreur comme la
facture dématérialisée aussi contrôler
les retards de délais de paiement
notamment de la collectivité la loi
pacte il vous avez vu que dans le même
temps votre partenaire à présidentielle
le modem a initié une série de questions
au gouvernement cette semaine
oui c'est vrai une chute laissez pas
léger soumission a quasiment toujours
appuyé sur l'essai c'est si le jeu
politique moi je prends ça pour un jeu
politique et c'est plutôt normal
vous savez on a l'expérience ce que vous
venez de me dire c'est un petit peu la
même chose au niveau local vous savez
les alliances jeu 90 la caisse sûr que
je voulais vous poser au mans locale
alors vous aimez ce que leur démarche
martinique et discutent avec le modem
martinique mais où c'est le modem
martinique et et est très très
silencieux en dehors des élections c'est
la même chose oui je sais j'ai entendu
j'ai entendu à l'émission nous avait eu
l'occasion de faire la campagne avec moi
j'ai fait la campagne avec max orville
j'ai pas eu de problème nous avions
convenu et notre porte est ouverte
nous n'avons aucun problème pour pour se
rencontrer
maintenant si vous voulez je pense qu'on
est deux parties totalement différent
pas opposer pas du tout opposé mais nous
sommes deux partis différents et nous
nous sommes en construction
il existe apparemment depuis longtemps
en martinique je sais pas s'il ya
beaucoup de monde chez eux mais nous
sommes en construction
donc commençons pas finir notre
construction avant d'aller voir les
copains voilà une dernière question en
quelques secondes
madame monsieur parce que l'émission
touche à sa fin de quel leader de quelle
formation politique de martine goût
votre mouvement vous en marche vous
sentez vous le plus proche
charlotte précieux ça on aura l'occasion
de pouvoir en parler très concrètement
lors de la conférence de presse donc
parce que cette menace le 7 mars
voilà la réponse ce sera le 7 mars si si
si c'est vraiment la réponse à votre
question je serai peut-être une autre ce
sera peut-être une autre orientation
peut-être que ce serait bien pour les
politiques donc vous commencez avec mon
occasion de voir il ya aucune langue de
bois a aujourd'hui que nous sommes un
parti politique et nous sommes très
proches de nous mêmes
voilà et bien voilà c'est si vous ces
émotions ces fortes paroles que nous
conclurons notre émission face à la
première d'aujourd'hui réalisé par
patrice à la guide pratique
l'émission réalisé avec maurizio lé ton
mais aussi charlotte gressier et jacky
le compte y est de la république en
marche
en martinique d'avant vente anticipée à
notre émission que vous pouvez retrouvez
donc un podcast ou en baladodiffusion
commune disons aux français n'est ce pas
sur notre site internet la première
point fr à bientôt
merci
face à la première
[Musique]